yeah so we got the story from
timcast.com by cassandra fairbanks
mumford and sons guitarist leaves band
after outrage over him praising andy
nose book
it's kind of a crazy story it's a roller
coaster of emotion
they say following intense backlash
after he he prays and he knows book he
apologized for endorsing the book
over the past few days i have come to
better understand the pain caused by the
book i endorsed
i have offended not only a lot of people
i don't know but also those closest to
me including my bandmates and for that i
am truly sorry
as a result of my actions i am taking
time away from the band to examine
my blind spots for now please know that
i realize how my endorsements have the
potential to be viewed as a approvals of
hateful
divisive behavior i apologize the
apology tweet
which was put out in march has now been
deleted on thursday he wrote a medium
post explaining his decision to leave
the band
saying that he wants to be free to speak
his mind
he mentioned that it wasn't just the
endorsement that was the problem
he goes on to mention that actually
apologizing
was the next sin that caused the mob to
come after him
so i find this to be actually an
interesting story because it shows that
when you're confronted with an angry mob
there's nothing you can do
so it's what should someone do cause
look it's not just the left
now we typically say the left is all
about cancel culture but it affects the
right as well
i mean listen i i just have a thing in
life and my husband will tell you this
this is like the one thing that drives
him crazy about me i will not apologize
for something
if i'm not sorry so like my husband gets
like two upon
she's a year on things there are a
couple times when i do things but most
of the time there's something like no
i'm not
i'm not sorry i'm not apologizing you
don't apologize
if you're not sorry for something and
you shouldn't be sorry
for speaking and having a differing
opinion no my version of apology is to
change my behavior
if i really am sorry for what i did i'm
going to make sure i don't do it again
and i'm going to do something better
that's
i'm not going to what makes me yell
about what's also
what's this thing about apologizing to
people that have nothing to do with it
like
you to me if you wrong somebody if i
wrong you tim
i'm sorry to you but i don't apologize
to the rest of the world that like this
is between the two of us this is a very
personal thing
like why have we dragged everybody else
in the peanut gallery
into this concept of apologizing like i
don't apologize to you nothing to do
with it this was between the two of us
like
this is a very personal thing that
everyone wants to get in the middle of
virtue signaling it seems like
well so shout out apology to the
atmosphere when when this bumper and
sun's guy
says you know hey andy great book you're
very brave
all of these people get mad saying
you're supporting the far right
so they are personally offended and they
demand he apologizes no i understand
that their personally offended
has nothing to do with them they did he
didn't tweet something to them so he
can't be sorry
to them you can't take into account
every single person
like you know to take the temperature of
every person that's why we have the
concept
of free speech right the the main issue
i suppose is that
the what's what really happens if you
step back is that mumford and sons was
set to lose money
and so he's like a bunch of people are
mad at me for doing a thing i don't
understand
if i do nothing and we lose money so he
apologizes
the apology didn't work they lose money
no matter what so then he says wow
apologizing was a big mistake which is
funny because
you know look my question i'll throw it
i'll throw it back to you ian what makes
you sorry for something right you said
if you did something
and then you were actually sorry you'd
say you're sorry empathy it's if i see
that you're hurt
i i feel that and i want to make sure
you don't feel that again
but what if people are hurt for
something nonsensical like he
recommended a book
or he didn't even recommend he just said
great job then i still empathize at your
pain but i will let you know i'm not
going to change my behavior because
this is why i feel it's righteous well
and let me tell you about the money
angle too this is very interesting
because
i at one point was going to write a book
kind of about the the actual financial
implications of these outrages
and people get very angry and they say
we're going to boycott something
and then they move on and so if you
think about
soul cycle or you think about you know
all these different companies that have
gotten caught up
i know very few of them that have
have had you know those kinds of
financial implications because people
were outraged now
there are some like major cancel culture
issues that have some
short-term implications but a lot of
times when you have these like big
brand things like oh i'm not gonna go to
solo cycle anymore like when's the last
time you got on a spin bike like never
yeah so it's a lot of times it's it's
this vocal minority that has nothing to
do
with your fanbase now granted if it's
literally
your fan base then maybe you need to
think about it but a lot of times it's
just like
a bunch of the course of trolls and then
they like move on to something else next
week and so i think a lot of times
people panic instead of just letting it
blow over let's yeah so let's we'll
think about the ramifications of you
know offending a fan base
should you just be especially in
politics a personality that just
says whatever your audience wants to
hear because then they'll give you money
or if you say something that offends
them should you just be like well that's
what i think have a nice day
even if you lose money i think you need
to be careful as a
business or as if somebody if you're
like fan driven or customer driven
like is do you want to have
a public set of opinions or do you want
to keep that
in your circle because you know reality
is like when back in my day when i
walked up hill to school
like the people who knew my opinions
were like a couple people in my circle
now we have dear diary that's twitter
and facebook
we take everything that we think and we
broadcast it to everybody
we weren't meant to take out information
so if you're in that kind of public
light and this
isn't like what you do for a living then
you might just say you know as a policy
like maybe i don't want to comment
on these kinds of things publicly or
maybe i'm going to send a note to andy
privately or you know whatever it is and
it's not because you're scared or you're
bad or you're backing down
but it's just that's that's not how you
make a living that's not your
thing and not that you should have to
censor yourself i'm not trying to talk
about censorship but i'm just saying
like
do we need to have everybody's opinion
about everything you're talking about
restraint and it's something that is
maybe you could argue is lacking in
society but it is a a detrimental it is
a very important
aspect of being a human is restraining
your body it is a wild animal that you
are in control of
and it wants to do things so you need to
be intelligent
and of course control yourself you don't
need to tell everyone everything that's
not the definition of honesty
the honesty is not lying to people but
you know it's just you use discretion
well it also stands so angry and also
staying because he's in a band i'm sorry
to interrupt you this guy's a musician
man and so am i and this is so
messed up that's all thank you yeah no i
mean and i think it's also just about
like sometimes just staying in your lane
not to say that the book thing isn't
staying in your lane but just
as a broader macro concept we're talking
about through the nuance of this
is that like you know i i'm an expert on
economic fine
and financial things like people who
don't know the difference between a
balance sheet and an income statement
like want to come
argue with me about stuff and it's like
i don't need your opinion on how to
organize the economy you don't know what
a balance sheet is
so it's the same kind of thing i'm not
going to wade into like
discussing the intricacies of like
medical decisions
or you know those kinds of things that
aren't my areas of expertise
i don't think and part of it is this is
just a nascent technology we're not used
to
this level of communication so i'm not
judging anyone this is we're all trying
to sort this out and wait it through but
like not everybody needs to weigh in on
every topic like
pick the things where you particularly
have that domain expertise
and you know maybe spend more time
listening on some of the other things
there's no upside to twitter
there's there's literally none and the
other side is the connections right like
that i've met some of the most amazing
people i mean we met
because of twitter we met each twitter
we met because of him but because i saw
one of your tweets last night
because of twitter you know a lot of the
people are watching like i've met
the most amazing connections and i've
collaborated on work
that is the upside to twitter but you
have to curate
that experience appropriately yeah i
i'll i'll walk that back for sure
there the upside definitely is
connections um like my
my uh communication with joe rogan which
resulted me
me going on the show was he was
following me on twitter he damned me we
talked
and yeah i think before twitter it was
you
you couldn't communicate with
high-profile individuals or celebrities
it was just near impossible but i do
think something interesting is happening
where
i think there is a push towards because
of things like mumford and sons
the celebrities are once again
retreating from the landscape saying
there's no point
and what happens is it becomes
journalists or i should say activists
so the largest component the largest
community on twitter for the longest
time has been
journalists arguing with each other
that's the biggest component of the blue
checks too right right
yeah it's like a quarter of them or at
least this was several years ago
and so they argue about things in
culture and politics
and it literally makes their careers
they get a bunch of followers
then the news outlets are like oh you
have 20 000 followers welcome aboard
we'll hire you
no joke these news outlets will be like
looking at some new hires
i want to be a writer well how many
followers do you have because you're
bringing that audience to them and they
know that you can push stories out
get more traffic make them more money so
their goal for many of many of these
people is to say offensive things
but say them tribalistically which
brings us to
the i i think the problem one of the
biggest problems we're facing right now
is
mumford and sons as you say shouldn't
wade into this territory necessarily
because
this guy doesn't know anything about
antifa politics and so by him expressing
an opinion in favor of andy
it's not his area of expertise he
exposes himself the other issue is that
when it comes to the culture war you
basically have
one main rule say what your tribe wants
to hear or else
people actually we see it all the time i
mean mike cernovich tweeted all the time
where people are like i'm going to
unfollow you if you have a bad opinion
or
i'm not going to support your book and
then he just says bye-bye yeah right
but that's not really retweets them and
says hey see you later here's the
attention that you ordered
i lo i love their their someone made the
meme of you know the virgin and the chad
and it was like the the the the virgin
i'm gonna unfollow you and then there
was a chat
i'll follow you for opinions i don't
like but it really does come down to
that because
i i don't think it matters whether
you're on the left or the right
you will get the same kind of pressure
if you go against the tribe now the
issue i suppose is
the left tends to be dominant in
establishment culture so they have way
more power
if you are james gunn you know you are
the rare exception where the right was
able to get them
temporarily canceled but on the left i
mean
they they can send turn a tweet from a
guy with 100 followers into
destroying someone's life so so that
ties back into sort of big tech and the
algorithm
i'm sure that any of you who are on
twitter have noticed
the kinds of things that trend are
always
bad negative baby types of things i mean
even
a lot of times they have the tweet level
underneath them and you'll see
something where it's got like a thousand
tweets or whatever
and it's like you know put right up
there in the trend so that people can
see it
and a lot of times it's calling out
people by name and it's you know
that's the algorithm there they could
put up positive stories right you could
trend
positive stories but that's not what
they choose
to put at the top of the algorithm and
we know it's not
just based on the the data and who's
talking about it because you can see the
number of tweets and there are things
that have lots of tweets that you know
kind of don't
register and there are things that have
very few tweets that all of a sudden
like oh you might be interested in this
take a little take a little smell of
this what do you think about that
what is up with people's obsession with
with drama and gossip
and all that human nature why is that
i mean i guess it goes back to nature
tribes yeah like trump's talking about
is that is that hunter a bad guy really
like is he gonna hurt us do we need to
take him out so they would gossip about
their tribe i guess and now it's like
all across the world on twitter i mean
yeah yeah twitter for sure
and it's be it's it's taken over
political discourse and politics where
we should be discussing what businesses
are doing how it's negatively impacting
um what government is doing that's
negatively impacting small business how
it's impacting someone's life but you'll
end up with a lot of people in the space
who are more interested
in i'm not going to say the guy's name
but ambushing stephen crowder
instead of actually having a legitimate
conversation and turning into a drama
moment for some clicks
and then you see newsweek at you know
coming out and being like oh and it's
like newsweek you're supposed to be at a
prestigious magazine
yeah you'll get you'll get people who
will like see a tweet from someone and
be like this is what we should all be
talking about and it's like half the
time
these tweets are from people who are
just sitting there like on their toilet
and they're like
and like you've got the most
breakthrough in science it's the most
epic breakthroughs in science ever seen
and witnessed by humanity in the last 20
years and like i i don't see much laser
spectroscopy advancement quantum
you know microscopes that are now able
to see 33 percent better
it's there's a new microscope that hits
cells without heat
so it can see it like 25 more clearly
it's like this
this is but millions millions of small
businesses
have been either directly murdered or
like on life support
and they want to talk about the drama
what's the solution
i mean it goes back to us right at the
end of the day this is
like we're the ones that have to
safeguard freedom or the ones that have
to make better choices i mean your
twitter feed
literally is your own curation you can
curate it
any way you want you can decide who to
follow you can decide how
to engage i was sharing with you guys
offline that like one of the my best
decisions for my mental health on
twitter
was to not respond to like provoking
questions or
explanations because it's just not a
format in 280 characters to have that
rich nuanced dialogue
there are people there are other
followers who will jump in and have that
and do that for them but like for me
that doesn't work i'm an empath i'm a
problem solver like that's that's not a
good combination
so i just think we need in every aspect
we just need to be more
intentional i mean we're so lucky to be
living
where we are and in this time and this
place in history and we just take
everything for granted and so we don't
put the dollars towards
the small business entities we don't
curate more positivity and lift up more
people in our twitter feed we don't
empower people to make better decisions
and at the end of the day america is
great
because of us it's not because of our
government or
even because of a piece of paper in
spite of government
you know yeah thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you